spd grüne cdu und fdp hätten keine
mehrheit gehabt
dann bleibt die frage wer hat nicht das
mandat in thüringer wollen und das ist
ehrlicherweise bodo ramelow gewesen der
zum minister der ehrung des abgewählt
worden bei der land hatten vor der
landtagswahl eine mehrheit sie haben
keine ganzjährig durch nur sondern nur
darum dass nämlich stand wir haben die
basis für ein breites nochmal die
architekten nicht daher kratschmer
zustimmen im wesentlichen aber die haben
wir noch nicht gesehen dass es auch
keine mehrheit gegeben hätte ohne
linkspartei und das ist das problem der
cdu in erster linie dass die
unvereinbarkeitsbestimmungen partei und
afd gleichsetzen diese komische hufeisen
theorie die eine verharmlosung der fc
ist eine verharmlosung der atheist
stunde weg wäre gewesen und der war ja
da mike mohring hat am anfang gesagt wir
können uns kooperationen mit
rot-rot-grün vorstellen kein festes
bündnis aber kooperation absprachen usw
dass das untersagt wurde so und jetzt
ist der eigentliche skandal dass sich
mike mohring und die cdu daran gehalten
hat die kooperation mit der linkspartei
nicht in irgendeiner form einzugehen
aber nicht mit der ard also ich sage
dass dieses hufeisen ding afd und
linkspartei sind die gleichen extreme
schon wahnsinn ist also für eine
verharmlosung von faschisten ist im
klartext aber wenn man schon dieses
hufeisen im kopf hat sich dann daran zu
halten nicht mit der stets kooperiert
aber eher mit linksverteidiger mit der
afg zustimmen das ist doch nun wirklich
wer will kann sie können sie den 1
[Applaus]
[Musik]
entschuldigung
die sache muss man schon klar benennen
vor fünf jahren hat die cdu die mehrheit
knapp verfehlt aber ist überdeutlich
stärkste kraft geworden
da hat es rot-rot-grün dreck
interessiert haben eine eigene regierung
gebildet jetzt ist ihre regierung
abgewählt worden und zwar mehr als
deutlich und es wäre eine anerkenntnis
dieser demokratischen wahl gewesen mit
dem mut diese regierung im
geschäftsführer im amt zu halten und
dann dafür zu sorgen dass bei wichtigen
punkten wie beim haushalt oder bei
anderen fragen staatsverträgen dass eine
mehrheit im parlament
bereitgestellt manche auch nie aber sie
haben das nicht getan wir sind absolut
bockig mit der brechstange in diese wahl
gegangen gesagt wir wollen diese
ministerpräsident mit aller macht wählen
lassen
auch wenn wir keine mehr da und das ist
unverantwortlich hier tragen ganz ganz
viele dazu bei dass wir diese schwierige
situation für die demokratie haben und
das ist ein gewinner gibt und er sitzt
hier was ich bin
wir fragen alexander gauland
fraktionsvorsitzender der fdp gauland
haben sie mit herrn kemmerich nicht eine
klassische eintagsfliege hingelegt wieso
einer eintagsfliege wir hatten ein
wahlziel die regierung ramelow zu
verhindern und eine bürgerliche mehrheit
herzustellen die bürgerliche mehrheit in
thüringen gibt es und wir konnten die
regierung ramelow nur verhindern indem
wir dann einen anderen bürgerlichen
kandidaten wählen sodass sie haben sich
aber mit sie haben sich in jedem fall
jetzt in dieser koalition
fd mit den stimmen der cdu und
der fdp in eine sackgasse manövriert und
wieso haben wir uns selbst und geben sie
den kandidaten aufgestellt haben denen
sich nicht gewählt haben
was macht der kindervater jetzt
eigentlich sehr traurig
demokratie ist kompromiss und wenn ich
sehe und das war klar dass wir mit dem
kindervater keinerlei mehrheits chancen
haben ist es doch klar dass man im
kompromiss dann einen anderen
bürgerlichen kandidaten wählt der nichts
mit der afg zu tun hat aber uns
natürlich näher steht als herr beck oder
herr ramelow und das haben wir gemacht
das ist ganz normal ich weiß gar nicht
ist klingt hier so als ob es einen
putsch war es war eine ganz normale
demokratische über also sie haben einen
ausgesprochenen anti afd kandidaten und
einen dezidierten anti höcke gewählt so
versteht sich herr kemmerich
warum haben sie einen so klaren feind
gewählt
es habe ja schon gesagt wir wollten eine
bürgerliche mehrheit
herr kemmerich ist ein bürgerlicher
kandidat wir hatten keine chance mit
unserem kandidaten durchzukommen
wenn ich also das land in unserem sinne
verändern will muss ich den bürgerlichen
kandidaten wählen der eine schon sie
fragen auch ein kretschmer gleich noch
nach seiner vorstellung von bürgerlicher
wird wohl sagen wollen die letzte
sechste last but not least kandidatin in
dieser runde begrüßen stellvertretende
parteivorsitzende in der linke frau
wissler was wäre unter bodo ramelow
eigentlich anders gewesen auch er hätte
eine minderheitsregierung geführt was
anders gewesen wäre ist dass man ganz
deutlich sagen muss dass die fdp eben
nicht eine partei ist wie jeder andere
dfds eine offen rassistische partei eine
nationalistische partei und sie wird in
thüringen von jemand geführt nämlich von
herrn röcke den man gerichtlich
bestätigt an faschisten nennt kann und
deswegen finde ich muss man ganz klar
sagen was dort gestern passiert ist ist
ein dammbruch ein dammbruch nach rechts
75 jahre nach der befreiung vom
faschismus 75 jahre nach der befreiung
von auschwitz haben cdu und fdp in
thüringen mit faschisten
taktiert und das ist ein absoluter
skandal und das ist heute dazu kommt
dass das jetzt korrigiert werden soll
dass es den menschen zu verdanken die
gestern zu 10.000 auf die straße
gegangen sind
die demonstriert haben die haltung
gezeigt haben gegen rechts sie gesagt
haben nie wieder und dem großen
öffentlichen aufschrei der empörung
diesen menschen das zu verdanken und ich
will noch eines sagen ich finde dieses
unsäglich dumme und geschichtsvergessen
geschwätz von den rändern und von der
gleichsetzung von rechts und links finde
ich vor dem hintergrund der deutschen
geschichte gefährlich ich finde es aber
auch vor dem hintergrund der nsu
mordserie was mordes an walter lübke und
den anderen 200 morden die wir von
rechtsextremen erlebt haben seit 1990
finde ich das gefährlich ich finde das
dumm und ich finde es eine relativierung
von faschismus und der gefahr die von
nazis in diesem land ausgeht deswegen
hören sie auch von den rändern zu
sprechen
sie haben hier mit faschisten paktiert
und das macht das so gefährlich können
paul wißler
er sage immer damit wir es verstehen
warum bodo ramelow diese wahl eigentlich
provoziert hat er hätte weiter
geschäftsführender ministerpräsident
sein können freilich einer
minderheitsregierung warum hat er diese
war gestern eigentlich provoziert
überall nicht provoziert die frage ist
was hätte er tun sollen also es ist so
dass spd grüne und die linke einen
gemeinsamen koalitionsvertrag gemacht
haben dass sie auch cdu und fdp zu
gegangen sind und das gespräch gesucht
haben und dass bodo ramelow sich gestern
zur wahl gestellt hat als
ministerpräsident die frage ist was er
in der situation hätte anderes tun
sollte sich zur wahl geschäftsführend im
amt bleibt er hat keine mehrheit gehabt
und ich musste sagen wenn die was mich
so beunruhigt ist dass es im
thüringischen landtag und in der
landespolitik offensichtlich keine kein
verständnis davon gibt es ein
politischer mitbewerber ist sondern dass
dort alle sich als feind betrachten und
wenn nicht diese wortwahl jetzt auch
sehen wie sie verbissen das ganze sehen
so wird das nichts diese demokratie
steht auf eine an einer harten probe und
die müssen jetzt dafür sorgen dass
diejenigen die vernünftig sein wollen
auch argumentativ von den worten habe
gestern wirklich und er ist noch eine
reine dass sie jetzt von ferrari hoffen
ich habe für irland ja ich habe nicht so
schöne ministerpräsident ich meine
sachsen hat jahrelang als sächsischer
minister nannte mich vor nach meiner
gibt nach meiner landtagswahl genau vor
dieser frage wieder gefunden und habe
mit sehr viel vernünftigen menschen von
grünen und der spd eine koalition
zusammen gebildet und zwar deswegen weil
wir alle nachgegeben haben weil wir alle
aufeinander zugegangen sind
und das ist meine erwartung auch für
thüringen mein einziger rat die nicht
geben kann und dass wir alle hier auch
in berlin wenn wir hier in berlin sitzen
ein bisschen den ball flach halten es
sind hier konsequenzen gezogen worden
und natürlich ist es eine realität es
gibt zwei polarisierende sender die in
der ausprägung unterschiedlich sind ich
habe die linkspartei mit der fdp gleich
gesetzt aber es ist ja wohl klar dass
diese beiden rändern nie miteinander
eine regierung bilden können und was wir
jetzt gerade erleben ist doch in
ähnlicher weise wie in der weimarer
republik das ist eine polarisierung
rechts und links gibt die nicht
miteinander kann und die mitte immer
kleinere
können wir das wirklich wollen kann das
ergebnis sein und dann noch einmal von
rosenfeld ganz genau dazu einfache
harbeck auch mit dem hufeisen theorien
es gibt keine gleichsetzung aber es ist
sehr wohl so dass verschiedene länder
hinreichend problematisch und nicht
gleich sind aber trotzdem hinreichend
problematisch für andere parteien um zu
sagen da haben wir keine schnittmenge
formal zu probieren und herrn ramelow
nein nein aber es gebe verschiedene
endlich an den missionen und nicht
mittragen da ist auch ob sie haben
gerade allen unterstellt die sich gegen
extremismus oder gegen länder wenden
allein zu verharmlosen umgekehrt wird
ein schuh draus dass es richtig gegen
jeden extremismus der unsere
freiheitliche ordnung gefährdet
vorzugehen und er sollte keiner der
benutzt werden um den anderen zu
verharmlosen aber es ist sie haben auch
nicht das recht die deutungshoheit zu
haben da wollen wir wieder zurück gerade
wenn wir wenn wir sachlich sein wollen
dann sollte man genau nicht die wortwahl
von weimar nutzen um das wie eine
selbsterfüllende prophezeiung zu machen
sondern andere wäre politisch hätte man
unter einem ministerpräsidenten bodo
ramelow minderheitsregierung rot rot
grünen minderheitsregierung nicht vor
einer ähnlichen situation stehen können
nämlich dass bestimmte gesetze diese
regierung vielleicht auch von manchen
stimmen der afg mit gewählt nein das
halte für nahezu ausgeschlossen
ja weil zwischen rot-grün und der hfc
die maximale distanz ist richtig ist
eine minderheitsregierung ist eine
instabile sache wie es zu der gekommen
ist habe ich schon erläutert es gab den
versuch von mike mohring nach der wahl
mit der linkspartei ins gespräch zu
kommen das wort aus dem
konrad-adenauer-haus untersagt daran hat
er sich gehalten
der rest ist dann bekannt das war glaube
ich die weiche wo falsch abgewogen wurde
aber natürlich ist eine
minderheitsregierung instabil und das
hätte auch schiefgehen können
trotzdem hätte man wenn herr ramelow
sich nicht der wahl gestellt hätte
gesagt wie lange will der
geschäftsführer im amt bleiben traut
sich nicht und so weiter also dann hat
sich das umgedreht ich möchte nur einmal
darauf hinweisen weil das gespräch ist
eine schlagseite bekommt
ramelow ist nicht schuld dass gestern hf
die fdp und cdu zusammen gewählt haben
der tabubruch ist gestern begangen
worden und nicht durch wodurch ausgelöst
wurde das darf hier nicht dass das hier
nicht wirklich um das jetzt nicht wir
sind noch mal so wir sind noch mal bei
der cdu in thüringen mike mohring war
das vielleicht einen versuchsballon von
mike mohring es jetzt auf der anderen
seite zu probieren und zu sagen wir
lassen da mal einen ballon steigen und
gucken um den preis dass die fdp herr
kemmerich am ende die früh geprügelt
dafür kassiert wenn es daneben geht
ich möchte bevor ich diese frage
beantwortete etwas was herr gauland
gesagt hat kann man nicht so stehen
lassen dass er sagt er hat etwas die afg
hat gestern etwas gemacht was ist ganz
normal ist wenn man den lassen sich mal
kurz ausreden wenn man weil man den
eigenen kandidaten nicht durchbekommt
nimmt man den kompromisskandidaten was
man aber nicht macht wenn man den
eigenen kandidaten nicht wählen will
weil man ihnen auch nicht durchbekommt
schickt man ihn nicht ein drittes mal
ins rennen sondern dann zieht man den
eigenen kandidaten zurück und sie
wussten genau wenn sie das tun würden
dann würde kemmerich gar nicht antreten
weil da das war immer die kemmerich
ansage ich will das werk emmerich
gemacht hat überhaupt nicht gutheißen
aber es war seine ansage und das wussten
sie
er tritt nur aus intrigen und links und
einen rechten kandidaten geht es für ist
angetreten sie haben ihren kandidaten
los laufen lassen wissen ihn nicht zu
wählen und haben dank an den präsidenten